pace explained to reporters that the
bears are ready for
every scenario if a first round trade is
available
they're ready to move up they're ready
to move down they've earned spot number
20 with their 8 and 8 record last year
that got them the 7th seed in the nfc
now a lot of this is obvious and
we've had fun with this on twitter and
elsewhere insert name of team
can trade up can trade down or use the
pick that they currently have
that pretty much applies to everyone and
the teams the general manager the
executives they talk in advance to the
draft
hypotheticals for instances what would
it take to move up what are you thinking
if we would
have a guy there that we like at number
12 could we do a deal
is it possible you have that foundation
set
so when you get the 10-minute window and
the team's on the clock you can
either get it done or not get it done
the thing with the bears though is this
because sims has in his mock draft
washington trading up
to number eight to take quarterback trey
lance they're at number 19
and the bears are at 20. the bears
when it comes to trading up and this is
something that sims and i have talked
about peter king and i
talked about it i go on the score in
chicago a couple of times a week and
it's come up there as well
because you've got this perception slash
reality that pace is on the hot seat and
that matt nagy the
coach of the team are on the hot seat
even though they've been in the playoffs
to the last three years it is kind of
weird
can you get clearance to trade up
and give up future assets that you may
not be there to use
for example to get a quarterback and
then you get that quarterback and you've
got a potentially
mismatched set of gm coach and
quarterback in 2022
if they do make a change and they bring
in people who look at that quarterback
they traded up to get and say
no thank you i think that it's going to
take the ultimate blessing of virginia
mccaskey
before they would trade up because as
the bears you have to know
eyes wide open you're essentially buying
a problem
you're either guaranteeing jobs through
2022 or maybe beyond
or you're going to put yourself in a
spot where it gets very awkward when you
bring in if you bring in new gm new head
coach next year
and they say god we'd love to have our
first round pick
this year instead of this quarterback
that we never would have drafted
yeah mike a couple things on that it
didn't work out so well as you said when
they moved up to number two overall to
take
mitchell trubisky we know that it just
didn't work out and
and frankly ryan pace could have lost
his job over that and some of the picks
that they've made in recent years are
not made in recent years because of the
khalil mack trade
those first rounders they they haven't
worked out quite like they had hoped
they worked out
i'm not an expert on the draft by any
stretch of the imagination but people i
talked to within the league
tell me that the drafts in 2022 and 2023
are going to be way better
than this draft so i believe them that
the next two drafts are going to be
better than this draft
so if i'm a team i am not trading draft
capital
for the next two years to go up and take
a player who might or might not make it
i'm going to sit tight if the
quarterback falls to me that i like
great
and if he doesn't i'm going to go get
another player and hope that andy dalton
could do enough this year to
to win for me or whether people above
ryan pace are making that decision
whatever
here's the other thing mike we know they
were all in on russell wilson right
russell wilson could be traded after
this year he'd be traded after june work
first for that matter aaron rodgers
could be traded after this year probably
not going to go to chicago but it could
be traded desean watson we know they had
interest in deshaun watson
he will be traded at some point i think
if you're the bears you sit tight
and you either wait to draft a
quarterback in 2022 or you wait to trade
for one of those guys
people forget all these guys could be on
the market next year and it could be a
great
quarterback driven free agency or trade
or whatever next year
if if these teams get rid of their
quarterbacks and it looks like they
could do
that so some of these teams are going to
be sitting pretty next year that don't
get their quarterback this year
and we know that the bears reportedly
tried to make a run to get russell
wilson but they just didn't have enough
ammunition to get
seattle's attention and also pre-june 1
seattle takes a 39 million dollar cap
charge to trade russell wilson
post june 1. it's 13 million with the
other 26 million hitting the cap next
year
that could be a post june 1 trade that
could be a deal that gets done draft
weekend frankly that goes through
june 2 we have seen time and again
trades get
done unofficially late january like the
alex smith trade to washington a couple
of years ago there'd been other trades
this year the jared goff
trade matthew stafford that was done in
late january early february and then
it's just pending
same thing can happen now pending we're
going to put the paperwork through on
june 2nd
to manage the cap hit that still is
impossible and i guess the bears would
still be a possibility although
we'll see how that goes also as it
relates to the bears oh one last thing
about chicago because i think the wild
cardi in all of this
is team president ted phillips who has
been there since 1999
he's been the one who's hired the
general managers and the coaches
if he is going to be on the hot seat as
well
then maybe there's a powerful ally
for pace and naggy if they are cajoling
for permission
to trade up if philip says i'd do it
because philip knows phillips knows
excuse me that maybe i'm going to be
gone too
that could be the thing that gets it
done but if the bears would make that
move up
you'd have to assume that at the highest
levels of the organization they're
comfortable with what that means what
that means is
pace and naggy had better be staying or
you end up with a mess
in 2022 when there's a new coach or a
new gm and
a quarterback that they may not have
wanted linebacker roquan smith the bears
have exercised the 2022
option on him may 3rd is the deadline
for doing it we're hearing about
more and more teams that are going ahead
and exercising the option
pre-draft most notably the panthers for
whatever reason
who knows they have if they have a
strong plan
they'll tell us what it is when they
feel compelled to do so
they have not yet exercised that sam
darnold fifth year option and perhaps
all that that implies and
you know i we played the other day scott
fitter or the gm of the team
when he explained that and i always like
to see
the actual comments because you get a
chance to read the poker face or lack
thereof
i think that
they aren't going quarterback at eight
but they'd like others drafting behind
them to think they
are and maybe be tempted to leapfrog the
panthers
and push down the board the
non-quarterback that they would really
like to get
that was my read when federer explained
it because he made kind of a little
smile
that made me think yeah this is a little
bit of a gamesmanship
thing here this isn't we're gonna pull
the rug out from under sam darnold this
is there's no reason to do it
and if we're not going quarterback even
if there's one there at eight
let's go ahead and make the broncos
think there is maybe the broncos will
jump up to seven
take a guy we were never going to take
and then the guy we want is more likely
to be there
yeah it makes perfect sense mike or
maybe they want to trade down too and
acquire some of those picks for 2022 and
2023
that they can get that we know the
draft's gonna be better in those two
years so yeah they're
they have had a great poker face so far
and what they're trying to do
but mike back to the fifth year options
too on all these guys
you know when teams pick those up that
tells you that they've drafted pretty
well right most times when they pick up
those fifth year options so you look at
a team like
chicago they didn't put it pick it up on
mitchell trubisky they didn't pick it up
on kevin white for obvious reasons
they initially picked it up on leonard
floyd and then said see you later
and get out so they have failed
in that fifth year option and then you
look at a team like the bucks mike
this is the fifth year in a row they've
picked up that fifth year option and
yeah jameis is gone i get that but mike
evans
vida veya vernon hargraves oj howard
they've picked up those fifth year
options because they've been for really
good players and that's
to me one reason it's kind of overlooked
in this in the bucks super bowl season
yes they got tom brady and they needed
him to get them over the top
but they have drafted pretty darn well
the last few years
other than kicks that's right that's
right no second round kickers or any
round kickers but
the thing to keep in mind this year is
the first time that that fifth year
option is fully guaranteed when
exercised it used to be it was
guaranteed for
injury only so you could still cut the
guy before the first day of the league
year
of that fifth year now the moment you
exercise it that money is locked in that
money is guaranteed that player is
either on your team or not on your team
regardless you're paying him
in that fifth year hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights
from nbc sports